هشام كنان طاهين جميعهم
طلاب جامعيون فلسطينيون تم إطلاق النار عليهم بينما كانوا
يرتدون الكافية ويتحدثون العربية في
طريق عودتهم لتناول عشاء عائلي في
فيرمونت. قبل أسابيع فقط،
تعرضت الطفلة الأمريكية الفلسطينية واديا البالغة من العمر ستة أعوام
للطعن 26 مرة في جريمة كراهية في  لقد
اضطروا إلى إخراج السكين
من جسده في إلينوي، والتجريد المستمر من إنسانيتهم
للفلسطينيين له عواقب حقيقية
سيدي الرئيس، وهو يؤجج
العنصرية والعنف ضد الفلسطينيين، والتجريد من
الإهانة والخطاب الذي يكرره
العديد من المسؤولين المنتخبين، وكثيرون في هذه
القاعة يحرض على العنف ضد
الفلسطينيين  قلبي يخرج إلى كل
عائلة متأثرة بالعنف وكراهية الإسلام والعنصرية
ضد الفلسطينيين وأي شكل من أشكال
الكراهية، أحد ضحايا فلسطين الذي
تم إطلاق النار عليه في بيرلينجتون هيم، كتب
أن هذه الجريمة البشعة لم تحدث
في فراغ بقدر ما أقدره
وأحبه  كل واحد منكم، أنا
مجرد ضحية واحدة في هذا
الصراع الأوسع بكثير، لو تم إطلاق النار علي في
الضفة الغربية حيث نشأت،
لكان من المحتمل أن يحجب الجيش الإسرائيلي الخدمات الطبية التي أنقذت حياتي هنا،
الجندي الذي أطلق النار علي  سوف أعود إلى دياري
ولن تتم إدانتي أبدًا بأي هجوم
مروع مثل هذا سواء كان هنا أو في
فلسطين، ولهذا السبب عندما تقول
رغباتك وتضيء شموعك اليوم،
يجب ألا يركز عقلك علي
كفرد فحسب، بل
كعضو فخور في  شعب يتعرض للاضطهاد
عندما أتحدث عن جلالة كينان وعلى
كرسي الرئاسة، أفكر في ولديّ الفلسطينيين اللذين
يعيشان هنا في
الولايات المتحدة